in your book notes to screenwriters you
say that some writers are just wrong for
some screenplays how so the the truth is
that probably the number one reason why
we find problems in screenplays is that
it was the wrong writer for that story
for that project it's amazing how people
will sign up for something that they're
ill-equipped to do you know from a hole
for several different senses right so
the first sense of being the wrong
writer for the project is just that this
project is too technical for your skill
level so this happens a lot with
people's passions projects where they
have this dream movie that they've
wanted to write since they were seven
but they and then they they start to
learn screenwriting and they start on
that movie and no that should be like
your fifth movie or your maybe your
third movie but certainly not your first
one and so so there's just the first
level is just you're not good enough yet
to take on a project of that scope maybe
it's too many characters it's too
complex in its story
the the structure is just gonna require
more from you than you're able to give
so and then the second and another part
of that is sometimes it's gonna require
a lot of research from you that you're
just not able to commit to especially if
you're learning your craft people tend
to be focused on learning the craft and
not have time you know to go off to the
yukon to research you know how Eskimos
you know make well meat or something you
know I think that that kind of weird
complexity that in a story in terms of
research is the wrong project to start
with so a research previ project
shouldn't be your first project a very
technical project with a lot of
characters and ensemble piece shouldn't
be your first project so from a from one
level that that you know you have to
measure the projects you take on
according to the skill set you have and
as it grows the projects can be more
complex and just think of it like any
other skill based craft if you're an
architect you don't build your
skyscraper first you know you start with
a dog house you build a garage and then
you work your way up so one of the
reasons the writers we see writers set
themselves up to fail
technically because they're just they
haven't really assess the needs of the
project and their own craft level and
another way that writers tend to fail in
this area is they're taking on projects
that weren't truly theirs to take on and
any story is is organically just
ingrained in the heart and the mind and
the soul of the writer and a writer
really needs to know himself and know
what kinds of stories he's uniquely
designed to tell and and stick with
those things and sometimes especially
when it's a job it's you know the
temptation is there to jump on that idea
and say yes I want to do that you know
I'm you know I don't know anything about
Eskimos but I can learn by gum and but
if if that's a story that where they
have no context and know not only just
personal experience but something that
really doesn't speak to their heart or
their mind or their soul then they're
not the right person for that story and
and the best stories come from writers
who can combine their own passions their
own interests their the stories that
really speak to them and who they are as
human beings and they're able to tie in
those themes that they're grappling with
and wrestling with as people as human
beings and then apply that to the story
or to the project and and that's a great
segue to the third wrong reason that
reason that a script would be wrong for
somebody and it has to do with emotional
maturity so you know if your theme is
going to be you know something very
gritty and intense emotionally or
psychologically you got to be ready to
go there and travel into that dark place
perhaps and and be you know you know
living it and a lot of writers just
aren't I had an experience once with a
project where it was about a
mother-daughter thing and I think we
tell the story in the book where the
producer said to the writer you're just
not going there and this seems between
the mother and daughter the tension and
it turned out the writer had real
mother-daughter issues and she was
afraid
go into that place so they kept trying
to get her to go there and she just
wouldn't because she's afraid what her
mother would think you know but she's
also afraid to you know she needed
therapy before she can write that out
you know and conversely some writers are
so there that they can't turn it into a
story and and that's the other side of
the coin is that sometimes writers need
to pull back from personal experience
and I you know when we when we consult
with writers a lot of them say well this
really happened to me we wanted and
we're like no we need to tell a story
with a beginning middle and end here you
know and many of our own personal
stories don't resolve that same way how
are you able to tell that maybe the
writers too close to the material that's
interesting well one way is when they
say this was this happened to me you
know you know then right then it's a red
flag yeah because you try to give them
notes and say you know this this
character is unbelievable and they will
say well that's what I did really happen
yeah you're not a character you're a
person you know the characters are not
people they're they're better than
people you know so I think that that's
one sign that they can be extremely
touchy about the material very you know
they're not able to just put it on the
table and you have the sense when you're
giving them feedback this is about them
and their problem with their friend or
their husband or their mother and you're
suddenly in a therapy session instead of
a note session you know and and they
people can get very defensive it's just
clear you know what you're not distant
enough from this material to be writing
about this but it's it's amazing how
many people want to write the story of
the terrible thing that happened to them
and in almost in kind of a way to
process it you know but this isn't about
entertainment you know it's like get
some therapy that's that might be a good
place to draw most people need a few
years between what happened and writing
about what happened in order to really
process it into something that's going
to work for more than one person
you